tout verte lors du jour appelle les
questions au gouvernement la parole est
un monsieur eric woerth
monsieur le ministre de l'économie et
des finances le quinquennat se termine
sur une information économique
accablante
la croissance française en 2016 est
inférieure à 16 de 2015 seulement 1,1
pour cent contre 1,2 en 2015 alors que
l'objectif était de 1,4 c'est ce qui
s'appelle un sacré trou d'air on vous a
alerté sur ses prévisions et réaliste
mais rien à faire vous avez préféré
comme la marquise vous persuader que
tout allait bien
si vous jetez un coup d'oeil à nos
voisins européens vous verriez que la
croissance britannique culmine à 2 % et
l'allemagne enregistre son plus haut
niveau depuis cinq ans avec 1,9 pour
cent vous féliciter ce matin d'une
croissance qui témoigne je vous cite
d'une activité dynamique
j'imagine que c'est un trait d'humour à
moins que vous ne parliez de nos voisins
européens la vérité qu'en france la
croissance diminue et que le chômage de
masse perdure votre prédécesseur au
ministère de l'économie se vantent
pourtant d'avoir fait un travail
formidable pour libérer l'économie et
relancer l'activité
mais confrontés à la réalité la loi pour
la croissance dite loi macron est
devenue la loi pour le ralentissement de
la croissance
bravo belle performance alors je ne
doute pas que vos services devront
trouver de bonnes raisons pour expliquer
ce mauvais chiffre
mais la seule chose qui compte aux yeux
des français ce sont les résultats
votre politique économique ne suit
aucune direction un jour je commente les
impôts le lendemain je les baisses un
jour j'ai augmente la dépense publique
le lendemain je l'a réduit les français
payent votre politique au prix fort
j'ajoute que l'inflation sera plus forte
que prévu avec une croissance faible
c'est moins de pouvoir d'achat pour les
ménages au delà de nos divergences
politiques vous conviendrez que si on ne
fait pas le bon diagnostic
on ne trouve pas les bonnes solutions
alors monsieur le ministre quand allez
vous enfin ouvrir les yeux sur la
situation de l'économie et de l'emploi
en france
la parole est à monsieur michel sapin
ministre de l'économie et des finances
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
vert le sinistre les chiffres ont été
donnés ce matin par l'insee il est donc
parfaitement légitime et normal que vous
interroger le gouvernement sur ce qu'on
appelle la croissance pour l'année 2016
comme vous le savez aussi l'insee est
donné des informations sur la croissance
au quatrième trimestre de l'année 2016
et des informations aussi sur ce à quoi
elle s'attend cette insee au début de
cette année 2010 est comme vous le savez
même si vous ne l'avez pas dit je
comprends que nous sommes dans une
période où il est difficile de faire des
compliments au gouvernement que par
ailleurs vous combattez la croissance a
été forte à la fin de l'année 2016
elle sera forte au début de l'année 2007
ce qui conforte les prévisions de
croissance pour l'année 2010 est que je
reviens je reviens sur l'année 2016
qu'est-ce-qui caisse quelles sont les
caractéristiques de ce que j'appellerais
l'activité économique en france au cours
de l'année 2016
la première caractéristique monsieur le
ministre vous savez regarder ces
chiffres vous avez été si je puis dire à
ma place vous savez les regarder et dire
objectivement ce qu'ils sont la première
caractéristique de l'activité économique
en 2016 c'est que l'investissement des
entreprises a repris et à un peu niveau
très fort et l'investissement des
entreprises c'est décisif pour
l'activité économique et deuxième
élément d'information pour la création
d'emplois parce que vous savez que
l'année 2016 c'est ça qui compte aux
yeux des français
c'est que le nombre d emplois qui a été
créée a permis enfin me direz vous de
faire reculer le chômage la deuxième
caractéristique c'est que la
consommation des ménages le pouvoir
d'achat des ménages ayant augmenté cela
aussi soutenu l'activité l'explication
de la différence que vous avez raison de
souligner je pas nier les différences
entre le résultat et la prévision ce
sont 1 0 2% qui tiennent à ce qui s'est
passé dans le monde agricole et lille
s'est même juge que ces euro véhicules %
de croissance en moins c'est une réalité
je ne vais pas pour l'année pour la pour
le reste l'activité tout merci